talking about insurance is never a lot
of fun because you're talking about
thinking or you're thinking about things
that most of us don't want to have to
deal with in life and I'm going to
continue that Trend by talking about two
new scenarios of insurance and that's
disability insurance and that's
long-term care insurance and sometimes
those two get confused
disability is a situation where if for
whatever reason you become disabled and
you're not able to work anymore
how are you going to support yourself
and support your family you are going to
need some form of income and so that's
what disability insurance is all about
you pay the premium and for whatever
reason you're not able to work because
you've lost your ability to work it
can't just be I don't feel like working
but if if the insurers say okay that's
what was covered that was one of the
scenarios you are no longer in a
position to do that job then that will
cover your income up to some amount
depending on what the actual policy said
now long-term care could be related to
it or it might not be above and beyond
lost income if you have some type of an
accident or disease that makes you not
be able to work anymore you might have
significant medical expenses you might
have to uh I mean these are situations
that none of us want to want to see
happen but you might have extended stay
in a hospital which can be very very
very expensive even if you are able to
maintain your income because of some
kind of disability insurance or have
some of or have some income it might not
be your full income because of the
disability insurance you now have a much
bigger expense because of all these
hospital hospital expenses and that's
what that long-term care insurance is
all about and it's not just for older
people it could be and I keep saying
this the situation none of us want to be
in wherever you get into an accident and
you have an extended stay in the
hospital it can cover that
so in some cases employers will provide
these types of insurances but they're
they're oftentimes not enough coverage
to fully protect you so if you're
worried about these and if you don't
have savings that can provide you and
your family a cushion if one of these
pretty horrible things happen to you you
might want to think about disability
insurance and or long-term care
insurance